every day i turn off onto an old country
road it's about a mile from the
presidents but you can see them
and then you get up to them and you
stand next to one and you go man
these things are huge
how many people
on earth can say they've got a
collection of presidents in their
backyard that you can see from space
i know there's jfk
i have 43 presidents
and ronald
these guys weigh approximately 14 to 21
000 pounds these things are huge aren't
they they've been here for about three
years and through time they're starting
to enjoy being out here they've got
their wildlife
got a bee's nurse
the weeds are growing up it's amazing
they amaze me
these statues were once a part of a
outdoor park
when the original park had closed its
doors i was asked to destroy the
presidents and clean the place up
it hit me i said i'm not destroying them
i'm going to figure out something
the feeling i get from them it's
it's overwhelming i mean these guys they
still have strength today that they had
when they were alive and forming our
country
they mean a lot to me
i want to bring them back to
a museum where they can be enjoyed by
everybody
you